[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm joined by
my co-host dr greg sadler and today we
are talking about
leadership
lying and legacy and it doesn't have to
be in any particular order the three l's
all kind of go together
and we have a particular case in mind
that we're going to be talking about but
i think we've got some bigger picture
issues as well so the particular case if
you know anything about professional
sports particularly here in america and
most particularly here in wisconsin the
person that we have in mind is aaron
rodgers the quarterback starting
quarterback since there's more than one
for the green bay packers and recently
we got to see
a side of him that was uh
surprising to a lot of us
i would say
and i think there's some other
emotions emotion words that go along
with that dismaying demoralizing
for some infuriating
um
am i what am i leaving out there's other
befuddlement yeah um
which is sort of like being amazed only
not such a good way
what else did another set come to mind
um
you said surprise yes um yeah
and i think we pretty much covered the
gamut there wonder in the sense like i
wonder what is going through this guy's
head
that could be one and
what are we talking about here well
he came down with kovid and he wasn't
supposed to come down with covet
although people do even if they've been
vaccinated and the reason why we all
thought it was weird that he
came down with covet is because he
wasn't vaccinated
and
apparently people within the packers
organization knew that he wasn't and of
course he knew that he wasn't but all
the rest of us were very surprised by
that
and this this broke you know the other
thing i want to say about this before we
jump right in so there were there was
some immediate reactions to it by the
media people who are already roger's
detractors you know
saying oh look at this terrible guy and
then he made things worse for himself in
a whole bunch of ways we're going to
talk about
but it's been almost a month so i think
that's enough time i don't know what
what's your view on this dan is that
enough time to get some sort of cold
objectivity
about what's going on it's not no longer
such of a hot topic
yeah the the hot takes have definitely
subsided and i think the old month is
definitely a good time for us to do this
retrospective and i do want to like
preface this
both greg and i
are fans of the green bay packers indeed
yeah yeah and i believe that we're both
fans of you know rogers as a
um at least a very much as a football
player on and have been impressed with
some of the things he's done off the
field as well in the past
yeah i would say that that's quite
correct and
i don't
want people to take what we're doing
here as just like character
assassination or anything like that
because we're not we're not doing that
you know the things that we have to say
here are informed by philosophy we've
got a lot of uh passages taken from
things people have actually said about
this including what rogers himself has
said which will surprise a lot of people
if they if they haven't uh
already
read it heard it
um
but there is there's something troubling
about this right
right and i guess one of the ways that i
like to look at a lot of these things
are
um this idea of of roles and roles that
people take on and so we all hold a lot
of different roles or you
often hear the
idea of um
i am a multiplicity
on that you know rogers has many roles
both as
quarterback and then also leader and
then community member and you know uh
fiance at the moment um
and uh you know family member and uh
just member of the general public um i
guess that i would also consider you
know him being a citizen yeah and
um we can all look at
how he acts in each one of these
different ways um and define that how
he's acted as either good or bad but
that doesn't necessarily follow that the
others have to be in concordance with
that accordance with that
yeah i think role ethics will be
something that we're going to hit on
quite a bit particularly in relation to
the leadership part of it you know maybe
there's some things that are
you know it's not as if ordinary people
who aren't leaders
can get away with doing things that
leaders can't
you know per se but maybe there's like a
spectrum you know you have you have
greater responsibility if you're a
leader we should say something though a
little bit just in case anybody's tuning
into this and they're like well who
who's this what are we talking about
what's the football you know
um who's who's aaron rodgers he's
you know our starting quarterback
uh for the green bay packers um some
people might need some explanation of
that that's part of you know the
national football league which is you
know for anybody listening overseas uh
obviously the american football
right
and um he's been around for a long time
he was drafted in 2005 which meant he
became part of the team
and he was
you know at that time we already had
like a star quarterback and brett favre
and then when farv left aaron rodgers
stepped up and became the starter in
2008 so you know he's been
basically running the show
for the offense
for what now is this this would be 13
years wouldn't it
yeah and
just to
give some more clarification the the
quarterback position is kind of like the
i don't guess you could call it a field
general it's the leader of the office
when the offense is on the field um as
well as within
um
nfl as like a greater thought um
you know the quarterback are usually the
face of a franchise
um as well as rogers himself is uh has
won the super bowl with the packers
that's a big deal yeah
and has i believe three nvp awards he is
that's right on the national stage yeah
and to add more to this um
he's what they call an elite quarterback
so he's up in the stratosphere he's sort
of the the person that a lot of other
people want to catch and perhaps surpass
someday but he keeps on you know
progressing
he also functions as a leader going
beyond the quarterback position you
could say that he's sort of like a
semi-coach at this point
i think him coming back um getting to
decide who would come back with him you
know they basically structured the the
team around him
that that makes him a little bit
different
and he has a really significant media
and advertising presence so you see the
guy on tv he has co-hosted jeopardy
i think that's you know that kind of
changed his status in certain ways as
well right he's had a cameos on a number
of tv shows including the office and
game of thrones right
right i forgot about that
as well as he used to be the
team rep for the nfl players association
the players union
so
that that is another place where it was
like the definition of what he was doing
and that role was to be a leader
so we're talking about somebody who
at least you know given all this strikes
strikes us as pretty intelligent and
thoughtful somebody who can exercise
leadership gender generally motivated by
by goodwill right
yeah he's done a lot of charity work in
the past and and
it's
at least you know from an outside
observer seems to be rather generous in
that regard like none of us can see into
the brain of aaron rodgers
this is an interesting thing that you
just said because
you're right we can't
you know usually we can only see what's
being projected out there but sometimes
people will say things that
open the book so to speak right you get
to see inside their head and what we saw
um is a little troubling
to say the least right
so let's let's tell some of the back
story about before we get to the the
significant day when he got kobe
um what is it that we didn't know about
what was happening
um so yes uh their
covet happened if you haven't heard
about that then you've been under a rock
on for at least a year and a half which
means that you're probably safe then
right you're not mixing with people
hopefully
[Laughter]
um
it is pernicious um but yes uh and so
there were like the
last season was significantly truncated
in the way of uh attendance um
they
made it so that like almost any home
game or
was
almost no attendance they've um
as we've got the vaccine we've uh the
wow i was saying we the nfl has relaxed
uh standards um it was you know early on
it was like if you had vaccines and you
could go into the games now it's
basically just
uh carte blanche but like the big thing
was at least in response to the the
requirements for the players themselves
as there are a number of
uh
protocols that
the nfl
uh negotiated with the nfl players union
and all sides agreed to these particular
protocols and which include things like
um
if you
uh unvaccinated players test positive
they are
uh have to re
remain isolated for a period of 10 days
and must be asymptomatic after their
turn
um other protocols
are on
testing every day wearing a mask in team
facilities um no in-person interviews on
without a mask or they are using a video
conference system
and um
a requirement to quarantine for five
days if deemed a close contact with any
teammate who has already contracted
covet 19. yeah so basically you've got
like the
20
20 standards which everybody was going
along with that dan just narrated and
then if you actually got yourself
vaccinated which it turns out you know
quite a few players didn't
and that's a whole different issue then
you're stuck with those old standards if
you did get vaccinated which the
majority of players seem to have done
then things are a lot easier for you you
know
you could still get sick but
if that player tests positive and then
they do two consecutive negative tests
24 hours apart they can go right back so
this makes a big difference for the nfl
where every week they are playing games
so
um
rogers actually said something about the
guidelines he said there's a lot of
conversation about it around the league
and a lot of guys have made statements
and not made statements
and then he said there's guys on the
team that haven't been vaccinated i
think it's a personal decision i'm not
going to judge those guys
so that makes it sound a little bit like
he's actually gotten vaccinated doesn't
it right yeah he's referring to them in
the them and not we
exactly and then he says um there are
guys who are that are vaccinated that
have contracted copen it's an
interesting issue that i think we're
going to see played out the entire
season so
you know
what uh what is that on
how prophetic yeah exactly
um and it makes it sound very much like
you know he's just on the sidelines and
obviously he's been
taken care of and well those other guys
i want to be respectful of them
and he's one of them
so
what else do we find out he
had an alternate treatment prior to the
start of training camp and then he
wanted that treatment
to
be considered the same as somebody who
got vaccinations
as it turns out that treatment was
homeopathy given to him by his doctor
if you don't know what homeopathy is
it's definitely not something accepted
by the medical establishment here which
is part of what you know often fuels
their oh we're persecuted and they're
trying to keep the stuff under wraps and
one way of summarizing it is to say you
take a little bit of something
to provoke some kind of reaction or you
know a little bit of something bad will
help you feel better
and there's there's no scientific basis
to it or you know
acknowledge medical basis to it
right you you put something into water
and you shake it up and then you pour
that out and have a little bit left of
that and you add some more water you
shake that up and you do this add
infinitem to the point where the water
has a memory of the thing that used to
be in it
um yeah so we're talking stuff that's
essentially pseudoscience right
and or if you want uh you know
alternative medicine but there's a
interesting quote i believe by the tim
mentioned that alternative medicine
if it were medicine they just call it
medicine well you know and i kind of
think
so this is a little bit of a tangent
some alternative medicine
is probably closer to medicine than
other forms of alternative medicine you
know like yeah i remember i had i had a
friend who was into homeopathy and when
i would get sick she would give me some
echinacea and echinacea actually does
does help you out a bit but it's not as
helpful say as antibiotics or things
like that
um and and you know it could be that
down the line 20 years from now 100
years from now there'll be a lot of
alternative medicines that will get
incorporated but the people who are i'm
gonna make a
probably a terrible generalization here
the people that are really really big
boosters of alternative medicine are
usually all about that
and they're pretty hostile to
you know what regular medicine yeah
regular i was gonna say traditional but
they often say that what they're doing
is more traditional right
right
and
i guess
i have no problem with alternative
medicine on
once it's been tested and proven to
actually have some effect yeah um i'm
not really interested in it um hopefully
it's uh
i guess that the big thing would be any
alternative medicines that actually do
have a negative
yeah yeah
now interestingly with this uh so rogers
petitioned the league and they took him
seriously and they had doctors look at
it and then the doctors doctor's like
this is not going to count as
vaccination
you know
it'd be like if let's say you did
something with
accepted medicine and you're like yeah
you know i'm just going to take
antibiotics every day the doctors still
would not be cool with that they
wouldn't say well that's just as good as
getting the covet vaccine you know
the covet vaccine in order to be
vaccinated you need to be vaccinated
it's as
basic as that
and and that comes down to
this this press conference yes
on august 2026 and a reporter asked him
point blank
are you vaccinated
and he responds
yeah i'm immunized
and now we're talking
semantics
and there's there's a name for
well there's there's two things going on
there one one is what we can call
ambiguity right where a term can mean
multiple things
so when you hear immunized in relation
to
being asked a question about vaccination
i think most of us would naturally
say oh okay immunize he he means being
vaccinated right but he didn't mean that
no
he's
once again we talked about it that he
had some sort of a homeopathic here
which he believed to have
made him
at least his immune system into
something that was
on
able to
fend off this particular strain of
coping or i guess this
family of coping yeah
so then he gets coveted and now the
story changes right he tests positive
for covet and a lot of people are like
well how did this happen you know it's
sort of like when somebody gets pregnant
and people like how did this happen and
you're like well you know we covered
this in health class it's not that
difficult to understand
right and a lot of people get on his
case so
rogers makes matters worse by going on
the pat mcafee show and giving an
interview
in which he uses a surprisingly large
amount of hard right language and claims
so i'm just going to read some of the
stuff he actually said
i realize i'm in the crosshairs of the
woke mob right now so before my final
nail gets put into my cancel culture
casket i think i'd like to set the
record straight on so many of the
blatant lies that are out there about
myself first of all i didn't lie in the
initial press conference during that
time it was a witch hunt that was going
on across the league where everybody in
the media was so concerned about who was
vaccinated and what that meant and who
was being selfish and who would talk
about it and
what it meant if they said it's a
personal decision and they shouldn't
have to disclose their own medical
information and whatnot and at the time
my plan was to say i've been immunized
it wasn't some sort of ruse or lie it
was the truth so now notice he's making
claims about other people lying
and that he didn't lie and what he did
was he told the truth so he is
either
lying at the time that he's actually
saying that in the interview because
he's saying untrue things about his own
statements or
everything that he's saying is is
completely true and then we should buy
that um narrative of witch hunts and
woke mobs and cancel culture which i
myself find a little hard to
to buy
i mean were you persuaded in any way by
this declaration
no
um
it was
when i first heard this because i
actually listened to this live yeah i
was like okay
this this isn't feeling
great and it just kind of got worse from
there in yeah oh yeah
oh
um so yeah we
using that ambiguity to try to
like you know
weasel his way out and to at least in
his own mind say i'm not lying yeah um
and
if you know that people are going to
assume
one thing with the way that you are
using words especially if someone says
are you vaccinated and you give a
uh
answer
you know
like in an affirmative sense
yeah i'm inhumanized yeah um
you know he says yes i've been immunized
which would be
demonstrably false if
you know when they asked you were you
vaccinated
that yes references the vaccine right
well see this is where we like you said
it's a matter of semantics right it's
how we parse it and this is where i
think
as a rule of thumb
when there's questions about whether
somebody's being truthful or lying we
shouldn't just like accept their their
story about what they really meant to
say or what they were
what they were
meaning at the time
we have to be skeptical about that as we
would with anybody else who's trying to
ineffect on us
you know and then this leads to another
one
he ends up saying that he's allergic to
an ingredient in the mra
vaccines um and that's why he he did the
thing he did i mean nobody knows whether
that's true or not does he really have
an allergy to it
um when you say a whole bunch of other
it's sort of like the
what's that old story about the the boy
who cried wolf right um you lie about
stuff a couple times you erode trust and
um it's i think there's a lot of people
i think who don't buy this i'm allergic
in a weird way that hardly anybody else
is
to these these vaccines
he also you know made claims um that are
coming from other people about how
vaccines could affect fertility and says
he wants to be a daddy someday and so
that's another reason for not taking the
vaccines
but if you have a reason
if you're using that as a reason then
you have to be able to
place some
evidence
that that is a thing in which it is yeah
and apparently he found some
things that are not really studies
but let's call them literature for lack
of a better word that makes those claims
but
they're not anything that's really
accepted in the medical community and
you can say oh the medical community is
trying to hide it but then we get into
all this conspiracy theory stuff and
then then we have to have like whole
different standards of
evidence and truth i think
yeah if he wants to be part of the
marketplace of truth he can't just
appeal to stuff that most people are not
gonna
gonna accept right
right
like
odd if he's making an argument to us
on
you know think of like a syllogism um if
this yeah we both need to agree on
whatever this is that you're on you're
making as your first uh portion of your
argument yeah and if we're not agreeing
on this then we're not going to be able
to continue on with that
uh argument because at least that that
first point isn't sound it doesn't have
enough backing
um to be accepted by all parties or even
the vast majority of parties
yeah there's there's
sort of commitments when you're involved
in public discourse that
you have to
honor and you know actually i'm gonna
jump ahead to something that
i i think is is kind of a lesson not
just about aaron rodgers but about
people involved in leadership positions
who end up lying about things often what
ends up happening is they want to have
things both ways
they want to on the one hand have their
status acknowledged and be able to claim
a certain space for themselves but they
also do this oh we all just have
different opinions you know and you
can't have both of these
operative at the same time you know if
all of our opinions are just as good as
everybody else's well then you know my
opinion that he lied is just as good as
his opinion that he didn't
if we if he wants to be believed he has
to sort of like
buy into the same
whatever we want to call it you know
um
rules of the marketplace of ideas or you
know
uh semantic requirements and then you
know there's there's a couple other
things that that came out of this that
are when we talk about these it being
troubling so he said that
everybody on the squad knew he wasn't
vaccinated everybody in the organization
knew he wasn't vaccinated i wasn't
hiding it from anybody
i was trying to minimize and mitigate
this conversation that would go on and
on
so if if everybody knew then why was it
such a surprise to all of us and if the
whole organization knew that seems to me
to be kind of a problem
you know it's like the organization was
also
covering for him as well
right
that's that's a big can of worms but i
kind of wanted to hit on you know
we've been talking about it yeah what is
lying let's let's kind of define some
terms a little bit yeah so that we are
or standing on some solid ground here
you know
there's a great book by this uh this
philosopher it's a classic now um called
um lying and it's by cicila bach and she
does this wonderful overview of like the
literature the philosophical literature
unlying all the way back to the
pre-socratics and going through to the
to the present and there's two features
that she
zeroes in on that most theories that
talk about truth and lying
make central one is that there has to be
like an intent to deceive
so
you know if i'm not actually trying to
deceive you then maybe i'm not lying so
for example if i'm you know pretending
to be a character in a play i'm not
lying because i'm not i'm not deceiving
you i'm not trying to get you to believe
something that isn't true and the other
thing is that that she um
says is really important for a lot of
theories
is if i'm lying to you i have to
i have to aim to substitute falsity for
truth or
something that's false for something
that's true and what this would preclude
it would be you know people who are
themselves
mistaken
so if roger's to take him as an example
if rogers really does believe that
homeopathy
is just as good or perhaps even better
than the vaccines that it's just as
effective then according to that he's
not lying he's doing something different
he's spreading misinformation which is
also bad
um he's being a rube
and he's been deceived by other people
who either were deceived themselves and
and then just passed it on or who lied
to him
but he's not lying in that case right
right this is you know this came up uh
a lot of times
in the last administration about like oh
they're telling a
it's an untruth they believe it to be
true but it does not actually you know
have a reference in reality
um but the question is is
how does one know
when someone is intentionally deceiving
and when they are
actually believing this thing and
they're just incorrect that's a great
question and so like with the trump
administration we could say
track record right i mean the guy spouts
lies all the time
uh a lot of the time it appears like he
he you know actually they called him the
the bullshitting president right because
harry frogford came up with this this
book that um defined that term and
that's
not just lying per se it's sort of like
a total disregard for what's true and
what's false anyway and i think that is
characteristic of
that administration and of trump there
were probably a lot of hangers on who
were deliberately lying um
but in the case of rogers
in a way his being in good faith in the
past and his intelligence works against
him because you can say
how could you actually believe this sort
of thing and put it forward how could
you not know
you know you're a smart guy
i don't know what do you think of that
that sort of response are are more
intelligent people do they are they held
to a higher standard when it comes to
truth and lying
or should they be rather
uh
this is
this is interesting on because like oh
the first thing is like rogers considers
himself at least a trivia buff and he
considers himself to be a rather smart
individual yeah and he has a really good
ability to retain a lot of information
um
but just like you know um i wouldn't ask
a
doctor to work on my car
um
nor am i asking rogers to do a lot of
things that are outside of his
wheelhouse yeah and so this kind of
comes down to um there's the
dunning-kruger effect
and when
you don't know then you don't know how
much you don't know
and
the problem is that he is a smart guy
on elise has a and and within the world
of uh football he is incredibly smart as
a quarterback he can like he has almost
identic memories about all of his
previous plays
um
and he knows how to dissect and and come
to really good conclusions that result
in him being able to be a very good
quarterback yeah um
but
um that doesn't mean that he
is really good
at uh anything else that is like totally
out of his wheelhouse yeah yeah
um and so you see this a lot with with
other people like businessmen or doctors
or whatnot who will you know pontificate
about things that are totally outside of
their
uh
direct expertise and because they have
such a experience of being either the
smartest guy in the room or the decision
maker they speak with really good
authority and they can you know
self-deceive themselves to thinking that
they know a lot more than they do
you know this is something that's
actually pointed out in plato's apology
where socrates is explaining
to the people who he's on trial with
and who are ultimately going to find him
guilty and content can condemn him to
death
why it is that prejudice has arisen
against him and he talks about
three groups of people that he's managed
to tick off by showing that they don't
know as much as they
claim to and one group are the we could
call them like the media people he calls
them the poets and the writers i mean
these days they'd be like the people
you know doing journalism or creating tv
shows or stuff like that he he claims to
show they don't know anything about
anything which is probably wrong
and then there's the politicians who he
shows are just
basically successful but don't know how
they're successful
but then there's the crafts people and
the craftspeople socrates says they did
know something they knew what their
craft was so if somebody's a plumber he
understands plumbing if he's a good
plumber if he's a bad plumber maybe not
so much you know
if somebody's an nfl quarterback if
socrates were around maybe they
understand you know the rules of the
game and how to do a hard count and you
know
even maybe some things outside of that
like how to hold a good conference after
the game and explain what happened
without sounding uh dumb
but that doesn't translate into knowing
anything else and socrates says the
problem with all of those people is
exactly what you pointed out they think
that because they're smart in one area
that they've got sort of a universal
smartness and and you know interestingly
in that interview
rogers calls himself a critical thinker
and being a critical thinker or doing
your own research is the popular phrase
these days
um there's a lot of ways to do that i'm
not going to knock doing your own
research altogether but if you're not if
you don't actually have qualifications
or at least a rudimentary
education in the field you're probably
not going to be able to do research in
any real sense
in that field even armed with all the
cool stuff that the internet makes
available like youtube videos and
wikipedia and webmd and all that sort of
stuff
yeah i guess one of the the
the most humbling experiences going to
college is that you go into your major
and you're like oh yeah i know something
about this yeah or me it was computer
science and i go in and i
oh this is a lot more that i don't know
and you get deeper it's like there's
even more that i don't know and you're
like okay well i need to specialize and
you pick this one little tiny like bit
of
the thing and you're like okay i can
become an expert in this really really
really tiny little thing yeah on but
is you know if you take it as like
filling up a circle of all of human
knowledge it is is less than a
thousandth of a percent of the diameter
um
not the dimer the circumference of this
particular wheel that i am aware of and
everything else out there like i i i've
got a lot of like general knowledge but
i'm not gonna try to make too many
pronouncements because
mostly i use my general knowledge just
to be able to have conversations yeah
and even if you're in a field that's um
less
exactly partitioned right
if you're an expert you spend a lot of
time saying well
i'm not really that sure about this or
that right rather than being the the
sage on the stage you know the guru the
guru types usually are
are uh full of it right
well we should come back to the story
and we'll come back to the lying stuff
and and some more deep dive but we
should talk about some of the things
that were
even more
problematic
um rogers got mad at the fans for not
responding to him in the way that he
would have liked he thought that he'd
actually like explained himself and
done a great job and a lot of people
were like this guy's totally out of
touch
and then he issued a non-apology and and
one of the things that i think we should
think about is are
non-apologies
really another form of telling lies
so he says i understand people are
suffering this has been a really
difficult time for the past two years on
so many people
we all know individuals who've lost
their lives people who've lost their
businesses livelihoods their way of life
has been altered completely and i
empathize with those things so far so
good right and then he says
i just want to start off the show
acknowledging i made some comments that
people might have felt were misleading
to anybody who felt misled by those
comments i take full responsibility for
those comments
now taking full responsibility this is
what we call a performative speech act
when you say i
take responsibility i am sorry i
did the wrong thing i will fix things
right these are all part of the language
of apology
but when you apologize to somebody and
you're saying oh i'm sorry that you felt
that i xyz or i'm sorry that i made you
that i
made you feel offended
that's different than saying i'm sorry i
offended you right
or let alone i did something wrong i'm
sorry i lied to you
he's not apologizing for anything other
than
people having felt that his comments
were misleading so he's not taking
responsibility right
it takes the the onus or the like
the
um
the person who committed the the act
um
from himself
making a statement that um
is very easily misinterpreted
um and says oh you didn't understand
exactly what i meant
um and thus that's your problem not mine
yeah and
i kind of think
that i mean there's one of two things
happening here either he doesn't
understand how language works and he's
kind of deluding himself which i find
kind of implausible myself
or he's he's doing something that's kind
of like lawyer-esque
you know and you see ceos of
corporations doing this when they make
bad apologies as well and nowadays they
usually get caught out on it people put
it on twitter and they're like look at
this non-apology
[Music]
i think if you say that you're taking
responsibility or you say that you're
apologizing
there has to be more than just
that statement backing it up especially
if the problem was
people fee it'd be different like you
said oh man i scratched your truck when
i backed into it
i'm really sorry about that you know or
i'm sorry that your truck so bad things
happened and i'm sorry that that
happened right
but if the problem is that you lied to
people in the first place
giving an apology that's not a real
apology is like adding a second lie on
top of it isn't it
right this um this reminds me
of oh in
i guess pop culture dan harmon who's
actually also from milwaukee
who's the creator of community as well
as rick and morty
um
i
was uh inappropriate with one of his
writers at work while he was working
ah shoot i can't remember exactly
um but he went through this whole thing
like the non-apology and i mean he made
a non-apology or
yeah and then he got called out on it
hardcore um
and
he then like went back and like realized
how incredibly bad that was
um
and and actually like
went through and made a really
um
sincere and
um
actionable apology uh that was actually
an apology and so the one thing that i
really want to get out of this is not
only do you have to take a
responsibility for the thing that you
did yeah you need to also figure out how
you can try to not do that thing in the
future as well as do something to at
least mitigate the damage that has
already been done by the thing that you
did yeah and otherwise it would just
it's speech acts you know it's like i
said this thing to try to placate the
masses for being mad at me when you're
actually not solving anything yeah
and this can apply not just to public
figures this can go for personal
apologies as well right
yeah absolutely if you think of like
your kids you go oh go go apologize to
billy
and they're like i'm sorry
um
and then they turn around like what does
that do
yeah it's like
you you've made someone say something
yeah yeah but does it actually change
any of the the feelings or the on
the way that they're looking at it and i
guess
for
children of that age it really reminds
me of like
on
to there's a technique of saying okay um
uh billy oh you you heard jimmy over
there on make the face yeah yeah and
make the face of how they feel yeah
because to try to like you know
hit jumpstart that empathy thing
do you know where i see interesting
things like this come up as a
professor
in plagiarism
so almost every semester i'll have a
student who engages in some plagiarism
and oftentimes it's because they
waited until the last minute and they
gotta copy something so maybe you know
they might be copying something from a
fellow student
or they might be
more often just copying something from
the internet and i can tell right away
you know that it's not their own stuff
if if they're copying it from another
student while i grade this stuff i'm
like wow this looks really familiar
then i try to see who handed them the
thing first or you know how things work
and if it's something from the internet
it doesn't match their own writing you
know it's it's usually better than their
own writing and so then i give them a
zero on the assignment because i'm not
really a hard case with this sort of
thing i give them a zero and i say i
caught you plagiarizing that's a
violation of the student honesty code or
whatever it's called at their school
and don't do it again you know because
if you do it again then i will be you
know i won't be quite so so nice about
it and the reactions are the things that
are most telling
so the good students will be like oh
yeah i'm so sorry i shouldn't have done
that i ran out of time this isn't me
you know and you're like okay well don't
do it again you know you know now that
i'm like looking out for it
so many other students will be like well
i didn't plagiarize i just like looked
at the website and i'm not sure how
those words got onto my paper but you
know i think i got some of the same
ideas like floating around in my head
and they spin this big narrative of lies
out to cover up the plagiarism you're
like just stop i don't believe you to
begin with you know and this is so
incredibly impossible
and you plagiarized it's an objective
thing i can show you where the the
things are are copied from
but this need to like
not have done something wrong i think
that's part of what what lies behind it
not to be able to tell oneself that no i
didn't do anything wrong it's like that
meme that goes around uh from the
simpsons uh with the principal skinner
am i wrong no it's the children who are
wrong
right
so everybody else in the world has to be
has to be wrong that's not a way to
restore trust which this is one of the
big problems with lying and this is
where we get to talking about the legacy
thing
it and leadership it really erodes trust
and that is what you need if you want to
be a full member of you know a group or
an organization
yeah this is
really the basis of
like
being part of that group um
and and what i
was uh what
came up to my mind
was like
i still like rogers
and definitely i'm not you know his folk
mob or anything i want him to be better
i this is definitely a
moment just like your students yeah as a
learning experience they had he got some
um negative feedback
um and if he doesn't want to have that
negative feedback in the future he needs
to do something to rectify that and not
you know and actually take
responsibility and not a non-apology
responsibility this is a good place for
us to
sort of jump ahead i don't think we're
going to get to everything that we plan
to talk about but
some of the reactions by others
in professional sports i think are very
telling
and i think one of the things that that
is indeed troubling about it is well
what you know the legacy stuff it's not
just rogers himself it's all the
different people that he's connected
with
so matt lefleur the coach
wouldn't comment on any player or
coach's vaccination
status which i think is a mistake you
know i mean if he wants to clear the air
he should like tell us exactly who's
vaccinated and who isn't
and then he was asked whether roger's
use of the word immunized was misleading
and he said that's a great question for
aaron i'm not going to comment on it
what do you make of that
well the first one i think that they
can't actually discuss
on vaccinations who is immunized or not
i think that's a leak rule
so i'm wrong about that then then saying
that he should do that
right um
but yeah definitely um
no the the question of immunized is
definitely within his purview of you
know
what did he take away from that
especially if he knew
um
what he actually meant by that and
everyone else you know reported it as
him being vaccinated yeah yeah he's he's
uh
basically allowing the general populace
as well as the entire on
crew of reporters
who are seeing him face to face
um
this lie in which uh he's
not actually you know vaccinated
that brings up another really important
point you know we often call the
reporters and the media the fourth
estate meaning that they actually have
like a stake in our community
and if we can't rely on people to
provide reporters with accurate
information
that's that's a real problem because
those reporters are the stand-ins for
people like you and me who don't have
the time to go and pester sports figures
or whoever else to see whether
they've they've done this or that thing
that they're supposed to do you know
it'd be like a thing and i think
like
i i do as far as i know understand
um
that uh he was
breaking protocol in having in person
maskless
conferences and he does make an argument
that's like oh well i'm tested every
morning
um but that's
you've agreed to a certain set of
um
rules both not not just directly imposed
on you by the league or the team but
also agreed upon by the players union in
which uh you know he is as a member on
you know at least tacitly agrees to
the
the rules and regulations of that a
governing board
and
so this is yeah this is interesting
because what it shows is not just rogers
violating something being a bad agent on
one side but also other people not
holding him to the standards they should
have been holding him to and andrew
brandt had something really interesting
to say
in his column he said readers of the
space know my favorable bias towards
aaron rodgers as a player and a person
even with my pro-era bias i can't defend
his comments
although some of the criticism has been
over the top his immunization answer
regarding his vaccination status was
intentionally misleading i cannot defend
it i get it he's seen criticisms
on players like her cousins and carson
wentz for not being vaccinated and
knowing he took an alternative treatment
he believed gave him
immunity intentionally chose to use that
term but it was wrong
and it was deceitful he knew what he was
being asked so that's that's the rogers
side and then he says it appears that
the nfl the packers and the
the players union all knew he was
blowing off that protocol yet we've not
heard about sanctions now there were
some a little bit later as to green bay
allowing this my sense is it had a
choice of either one upsetting its
superstar and forcing him to mask up or
two appeasing him
while noting other violations around the
league and accepting whatever comes in
the form of penalty
so
you know when when rogers
you know violates these rules and also
lies about it doesn't just look bad for
him or not just look bad it doesn't just
reflect a
lack of trustworthiness and truthfulness
on his part it also reflects it on the
league and the packers organization and
you know to jump um to one of the
repercussions from this um state farm at
first seemed like they were taking his
commercials completely out of rotation
and then state farms said
you know because he's got all these
these commercials with them they said
we don't support the statements that
he's made but we respect his right to
have his own personal point of view
our mission at state farm is to support
safer stronger communities to that and
we encourage vaccinations but respect
everybody's right to make a choice based
on their own personal circumstances
which is kind of just lawyer talk for
you know we're gonna let people do
whatever they want and so they kept his
commercials on and then they lowered the
amount of commercials about 90
so very few of his commercials were
getting through
and then they wouldn't admit that they
were doing that they when they were
questioned about it they said oh you
know we just kind of like you know we
strategically put commercials this is
all a bunch of corporate gobbly [ __ ]
so so in effect rogers drew state farm
into this morass of
self-serving lying you know
and it looks bad for state farm whereas
like that you know previa health they
ended their partnership with rogers
um over over this they they took a hard
stance they were like nope we're not
doing it
i was kind of disappointed to see state
farm who originally looked like they
were going to back off from this and say
listen unless you get your act together
you're not you're not
going to be doing these commercials for
us i was kind of disappointed to see
them and i like the state farm
commercials
i was disappointed to see them um
take the the route that they did and i
kind of feel like um
i mean it's kind of stupid i suppose on
my part to expect an insurance company
to be upstanding and you know truthful
and stuff like that you know especially
in advertising which is by its very
nature
almost always deceptive
so that may be foolish on my part
but i kind of think state farm got
tarnished and i kind of think the nfl's
got tarnished and i kind of think the
packers organization is getting
tarnished by this
yeah
it makes sense that the the one
organization that stuck to their guns
hard was a medical organization and yeah
you have someone who
is espousing things that are
the opposite
core values
of that medical organization yeah i
would also absolutely i i can
i'm not endorsing the other people for
their decisions um but i understand
why they have made them because they're
uh
they see well rogers makes a lot of
people a lot of money that's true and it
is in their core interest to keep that
flow on but this is the same reason that
many many powerful and rich individuals
throughout history
who've had you know
laws and rules they don't not quite
apply to them because they're it's in
too many other people's interests to
keep them where they're at yeah
you know you mentioned like this could
be a teachable moment or you know time
of reflection
doing that sort of thing coddling is
least likely to produce that effect
right it's only when you actually hold
people's feet to the proverbial fire
that it's likely that they're going to
feel a sense of being convicted or
however else you want to put it you know
going you brought up medical people and
i did have a few quotes here from some
medical professionals
one person dr william uh schaffner
uh said any very public figure who first
of all is duplicitous and then makes
misstatements certainly is contrary to
what we're trying to achieve from a
public health perspective and that's
that's very
clear right he says immunize has a very
specific meaning it's in the dictionary
it doesn't mean some non-specific
protection
so that's what doctors have to say about
that
i think that's kind of important and
then al dr allison natesel said
it's just as disappointing as a
wisconsinite as a packers fan as a
doctor we're fighting this twin pandemic
of coronavirus but also this
misinformation
he's meaning roger's in a position to
really motivate the state of wisconsin
and the nation at large to get
vaccinated you know and our vaccination
rates here in in wisconsin
are still in the as far as i know 50s at
this point in time you know we have a
long way to go and that's you know
that's not people who've got boosters
that's like people who got their first
round
so
you know
what about this thing about setting an
example
you know you started out talking about
roles early on this is something that
ties in with leadership and with legacy
is roger's
not put put aside the lying part
the not getting immunized this endorsing
you know
pseudoscience and stuff like that as an
alternative for vaccination
is that setting a bad example that that
is ethically problematic
i would say so um although i'm
not
totally surprised um you know you if you
followed rogers for years like i have
yeah you know he's he's every once while
he says something is like a little bit
like head scratchy like he likes ufos
and whatnot it's like
a lot of
most part i threw that out way because
like okay people can like ufos and stuff
without actually believing that they are
in fact real right um
i guess as well as like i don't know how
much time you spent in northern
california um there's there's lots of
people there that are very into like
crystals and whatnot and so like i don't
know uh and
i'm not going to say he specifically
endorses any particular thing yeah yeah
um but he's definitely in
the milieu of the things that he's been
exposed to throughout his life that
could lead him to some of these
conclusions
yeah i think there has to be sort of
like you gotta have a kind of critical
mass of them or there has to be like a
catalyzing moment where he's like yep no
vaccine just homeopathy for me where
you're like oh
indeed he does go that way you know
i think i think you're right that he he
got the benefit of the doubt
um
about a lot of these things
in the past
what about the lying i mean is he
is he presenting
you know is it bad for
his team for him to be doing this he is
the
the uh you know essentially the captain
um
is it bad for
the fans is it bad for kids who you know
have a rogers jacket and look up to him
or
i would say as a member of the team yeah
a lion is going to degradate that in as
the role of the team leader it degrades
the
uh organization it's a packers football
team um because
um once again it degrades the trust that
we put into
them especially because they carried his
water on and you extend this to the the
nfl and anyone else organizations that
that were also privy to this information
and kept it under wraps yeah yeah um
and and it's not like the nfl has like a
super great track record of this already
they kept a lot of the the concussion
stuff yeah exactly uh under wraps and um
and tried to sweep that on the table for
many many years yeah once again like
yeah and in their business to do that
that is by
changing the way that you handle this
right so yeah you know somebody might
say you know you don't know what it's
like to be
a franchise quarterback and the pressure
that entails and all that
and i got a quote from somebody who went
as soon as i saw it on on i didn't see
it live on tv but i saw it posted i was
like wow this is
the ultimate you know refutal of any
sort of attempt to try to get him off
the hook on that way
and it's terry bradshaw terry bradshaw
said i'll give aaron rodgers some advice
it would have been nice if he'd just
come to the naval academy and learned
how to be honest learned how not to lie
because that's what you did aaron you
lied to everyone
i understand immunized what you were
doing was taking stuff that would keep
you from getting covered 19 you got
coven 19. and then he goes off on he
says you know i've ever met him as a
cattle dewormer sorry folks that's what
it is and so he's basically saying you
know you should have known better and
you shouldn't have lied about this and
he says he ends it by saying i'm
extremely disappointed in aaron rodgers
so when you have a
you know one of the one of the best
quarterbacks you know
in history who's a commentator on the
sport himself
saying that i think that's kind of
telling
the last thing i want to say before we
close out is
one has to look at what gain what one
gains from lying versus what
one has lost
and if you weigh these two things the
scale and what he is lost with the
airing of the reality of the thing is
much better than any of the you know as
he said on
removal from that scrutiny that he
wanted in the first place
so this is a great case um do you want
to lead us out with with a uh yeah
passage we leave you today with the
words of sisela bach
trust and integrity are precious
resources easily squandered hard to
regain they can thrive only on a
foundation of respect and veracity
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you